well the nation's top generals will
brief Congress today on Syria after the
weekend's us-led missile strikes that
follows president Trump's decision to
hold off on new sanctions against
Russian companies tied to Syria's
alleged chemical weapons program major
Garrett is traveling with the president
and he's in West Palm Beach Florida
major good morning good morning the
administration vowed new sanctions on
Russians linked to Syrian chemical
weapons now those sanctions are on hold
president Trump said he won two whole US
forces out within six months now there
is no timetable so amid the precision of
US missile strikes in Syria there is
confusion over the Syria strategy did
our generals do a great job
speaking in Florida Monday President
Trump boasted about the u.s. strike on
Syria but confusion about Russia
surfaced after the missile strikes you
will see that Russian sanctions will be
coming down UN Ambassador nikki Haley
said new sanctions on Russia would come
Monday but then President Trump
intervened delaying a decision White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders said
more sanctions were merely under
consideration Russia must decide if it
will continue down this dark path
despite rising tensions with Russia over
Syria president Trump still wants a
White House summit with Russian
President Vladimir Putin we're gonna
have to get serious about sanctions on
Russia Arizona Republican Jeff Flake
said the confusion over Syria made the
u.s. look weak
it's not a good sign if we're walking
back statements made just a couple of
days ago the White House said the
missile strikes were designed to [ __ ]
Syria's chemical weapons arsenal with
way over a hundred missile chaton they
didn't shoot one down but a pentagon
analysis has concluded Syria can and
likely will rebuild its chemical weapons
stockpile and the missile strikes did
nothing to change the seven years civil
war the military strike itself was a
tactical response well short of what I
thought was justified lawmakers like
South Carolina Republican Lindsey Graham
were left to wonder what was achieved so
it's been a good commander in chief in
general but this is a
major step backwards the White House is
trying to persuade Arab nations led by
Saudi Arabia to send troops to Syria
Egypt Qatar and the United Arab Emirates
are also on the list it's unclear when
the troops would arrive or how effective
they might be one potential upside US
forces might be able to leave earlier
one risk widening the conflict by
clashing with Syria's top regional ally
Iran John Major Thanks